he's the most senior member of islamic
state ever to face trial in a u.s court
el shafiel sheikh is alleged to be one
of a group of british men who captured
and murdered western hostages in syria
they were nicknamed the beatles by their
victims a way of shattering the
anonymity of the men behind the masks
prosecution lawyer john gibbs told the
jury the defendant played a central role
in a brutal hostage-taking scheme the
abuse was unrelenting and unpredictable
they seemed to enjoy beating the
hostages
mohammed emwazi nicknamed jihadi john
was filmed carrying out the beheadings
the prosecution say el shaikh was his
accomplice but the defense claimed he
was a simple is fighter lawyer edward
mcmahon said the evidence will be
inconsistent released hostages will tell
a different version of who the beatles
were you will hear different versions of
who is john ringo george you might even
hear of paul another british man
in 2018 al-shaikh and alexander coaty
who has now admitted to being one of the
beatles gave an interview to sky news
despite what the media says that we are
human beings
and
we do have empathy
and also despite what the media says we
haven't been
formally charged or convicted of
anything
journalist james foley was murdered in
syria in 2014.
his mum diane pushed to bring his
suspected killers to the u.s
i'm just kind of incredulous that he's
pleading innocent and only time will
tell
that is the good thing he's going to get
a fair trial it's in stark contrast
obviously to what our son james
endured
bethany haynes the daughter of murdered
scottish aid worker david haynes was
also in court she hopes the trial will
reveal the location of her father's
remains
the dignity and decency of this justice
process is diametrically opposed to the
horrors of a far away land which are
being recounted in court for the
families of el shaikh's alleged victims
this is the culmination of their long
battle to see some semblance of justice
served martha kellner sky news virginia